hello welcome to another GameSpot
unboxing I'm Daniel are joined by mr.
Kevin Bernard who is reviewing the Elder
Scrolls online but here's a boxed copy
of us this is the hugest thing by the
way I think I've ever received email
this is the Imperial Edition it's a 99
bucks apparently although it's mostly
sold at a lot of places it is but you
know what if you really want if you
really want some cash I we saw that it's
selling on Amazon for like 200 bucks
like different folks so that's let's see
what's inside of it should be this puppy
if you're gonna want to we're not going
to though
now we're not going to we should open it
yeah you however what do the honors how
do you open these don't tear the thing
apart I wanna tear it apart that's the
fun part here you do the opening because
I'll just
it's like Christmas the most fun part oh
here we go here we go it's like the size
of a like an Xbox one it is actually
it's like the size of a console that's
what it looks like inside it's all it's
all velvet and lovely and it smells like
dead horses which I really appreciate oh
god that's what dead horses smell like I
know I stopped that's why I used to work
in the horse mortuary okay so what we
got here so here is it well okay
Imperial Edition so the game is
apparently in here so so let's see what
we got so discs discs one through four
the game apparently appears on discs one
and four so unlike the digital version
which you just download with this person
you get to install the game as well
which is like playing games from from
today's combine good times good times
good times but at least we got the
option and then codes that give you
vanity pets you can play any race in any
alliance Wow which is not something
everybody gets so I'll let you debate
whether you think that that's a good
thing to hide races and things like that
behind a paywall on a bonus treasure map
bonus treasure but it's digital it's a
digital treasure map because who's got
room for all those clock maps from
today's games
here's game registration code here is an
ad one side is the evil within
it's got here oh oh hi on the other side
and the other on the other side is
Wolfenstein the new order a game we also
know is going to be selling an
incredible collector's edition it is not
going to have four giant DVD
it's gonna have nothing yet apparently
it's just an empty box
we spoke too soon on the line map you
get a digital map but here you have the
real one that made it of the real map it
made of real paper Oh which I which may
or may not flee rips okay I the duck he
didn't really write that come up on the
microphone it was just an intern here
I'll help you've got a delicate touch
Kevin no no no I don't look it's it's
it's all of tamriel there you go hammer
fell and Skyrim and Sarah dill and Mara
wins oh yeah I'm ready
all of the Tamriel all of the Tamriel
it's very nice it's very nice yes yeah
so that one weird in here what else is
in here well you know that there always
has to be some kind of a figure Ange
there better be for a hundred bucks for
a hundred bucks there better be a
figurine right so there's a figure so
let's uh let's see if I can untwist it
okay you want twisted I think to see if
I'm better it just something I think and
I am it unboxing oh there's something
down there it's probably an art book I
would imagine that seems like the kind
of thing that we would do oh I like this
let's meet on sheepish you say that this
may actually be the nicest book I've
ever seen in a special edition um this
is a this is a pretty awesome wow this
is actually pretty pretty great and this
is a an art book with lots of
information as well actually it's not
just you're not just a gallery of
screenshots printed on paper and but I
have to say the the finish on this this
is like legit leather-bound yeah it's
actually pretty nice okay because I'm
spoiling to open up and show people like
the first age or something you don't
know oh did you okay I was a little
sighs I was too busy failing at
untwisting to be spoiler if I opened up
the last page to show them what happened
at the end of the game look at this
because you're sure that's what's in
there it's even got its own little
velvet bookmark look at this I gotta say
this is pretty great I'm into this yeah
that's quite lovely what's that language
first day of school
Oh what actually is English I was
looking at it upside down I thought it
was some kind of elvish
I actually have this almost untwisted so
well it's great because that's why they
give you the books you can read all of
this while your friend tries to take it
that's right okay it's official that I'm
better at untwisting that I am it
unboxing oh did I break anything I hope
no I don't think I broke anything
there's still something there it's heavy
oh it's the base we have to get the base
can you check the base I'm gonna have a
look at this dude who appears to be some
sort of massive I'm going to say it's
some sort of a massive Daedra I'm sorry
they hide it underneath the thing you
have to actually get it out of the
plastic down here I'm gonna oh oh I
didn't break it I hope I broke it for a
moment but the tails just separate this
is a this is a model that you must
construct yourself which which should
take upwards of 30 seconds hopefully and
don't forget there's a tail we can't
forget the details you know what this is
is it some sort of daydream man yeah he
looks like like one of those dudes make
sure you have a friend to help with the
construction and then we'll figure out
how to stick this - there you go I'll
stick it and then we just arrived on the
right way no sorry I don't stick that
thing in there like like that it's kind
gentle very gentle Joby chose there and
how many lubricant oh I'm just not any
good at putting a round peg for a square
hole okay that that there we go okay we
got how are you guys we got us look at
this dude he's got he's got this big
knife that we you look at you if close
close-up on that on little dude up there
because that's you right like you think
you're all huge and awesome wearing that
armor and then look at this big thing
it's covered oh my god and you're in its
grasp it's pretty good I like it and I
I'm pretty sure you're not gonna die in
this situation II a pretty crappy end to
the game you know do you've any idea
what the hell this thing is
I don't some sort of Daedra man does it
say on the box it would be I think
cager man is probably the MA
oh my god how could I not know
you know you hear his voice like all
that's not like that that's the thing
though I like associate Molag Bal with a
voice not with an actual figure turns
out he's pretty big intimidating yeah
there you go is the Imperial edition of
the Elder Scrolls online and Vale about
well it was available and I online
retailing stores maybe it's maybe it's
in some brick-and-mortar places still at
99 bucks if you haven't pick it up and
of course you got a month of the game
free as well with your with your Elder
Scrolls online and then you have to have
to pay like the traditional MMO yeah as
of days passed and coming soon
Wolfenstein new order unboxing with no
discs exactly yeah look forward to that
in upcoming times on GameSpot calm
[Music]